President Trump is working hard to bring
jobs and opportunity back to our shores
Carrier, Ford
and most recently with his
Dissent Based Stimulus Plan
[TRUMP] I love protesters
[TRUMP] I'm going to develop my own protesters
what you thought were just
swiftly signed unpopular executive actions
are actually tools for reviving the
flagging protest economy
bringing prosperity back to marker manufacturers
posterboard companies
pink yarn distributors
ACLU accountants
starbucks window repairman
Lyft drivers
immigration lawyers
Democratic exploratory committees and more
Trump isn't causing protest
he's kicking off stimulus
and uniting the country
pumping more than 2.4 quadrillion zillion dollars
into the US economy
and saving all the jobs
all of them
you're welcome America
[TRUMP] I'm going to develop my own protesters